I love this man's work when he's
nominated twice for Emmys for his work
playing detective James Martinez on NYPD
Blue you also loved him in the district
Third Watch Blue Bloods and so much more
and now if you follow him on twitter at
nick tutorial one and also on instagram
you see his die-hard Yankee fan them on
display good to see you Nick to Toro
you too buddy pleasure to be here yeah
you know what it's it's it's um it's
good to see you where you're probably
you're sitting in a rocking chair for
the next four or five days Yankees just
swept the twins last night it's okay I
can enjoy this victory
you know I earned it I'm working hard
like I said I don't just root I'm I
prepared during the day and you know
prepare mentally I have to get ready and
I mean have to get ready you know and to
do my preparation I got to get in the
right frame of mind I got to be ready
for the game so when the game comes on
there's no distraction and I get in the
right seat maybe have the right t-shirt
like lately I've been wearing a Yankee
t-shirt it's been working usually I
don't like to wear anything with the
logo on it sometimes I feel like that's
a jinx
but this has been working so you're
you're a type of guy that figures if
it's not going the Yankees way it's
because the way you're sitting or what
you're wearing oh yeah they literally
believe that oh yeah I literally believe
that like somebody can walk in the room
and I'll go like who's this guy he might
turn the whole between the cracks in a
room it doesn't care for like one time
my brother-in-law was sitting in the
chair against the Red Sox and the guy
had a bomb and then he came to next
night and I said you sat there last
night and he goes yeah I go no I'm to
sit over here cuz I can't City I said
sit over there you were there last night
you screwed everything up okay I don't
care if it's a brother-in-law you know I
mean I mean I throw my hat sometimes
when I get mad that might turn it I go
all right leave the Hat drop the
baseball leave the baseball I'm telling
you like last night I brought out the
broom and Chatham was starting to sweat
me out right I go get that broom at it
right now
don't fool around right now with the
Mojo I can you know I can do that in my
house when I'm at the stadium at least
I'm with people like me that I can
relate to so I don't have to do that
it's harder to watch than that
participate because you have no controls
like on an airplane you your life you
could die you're like you know you go
like that when you land and whatever so
you're out of control at least when
you're acting or you're doing the scene
right it's you right you can screw it up
or you know you have control of it but I
feel like I could turn things sometimes
I just feel like if I'm there like an
even though that what the Astros I feel
like if I'd go to age town I could beat
those Cowboys right in that Stadium
somehow my mojo I almost did it once in
2001 and the Diamondbacks game seven
yeah it was working it was freakin
working people were calling me when
Soriano hit a home yeah I said don't say
bingo this you're doing it you're doing
it I say no I know and then it was that
stupid bunt when Mariano threw the ball
to second never should've did that
change the whole energy food chain I was
almost in tears imagine driving back in
the desert five hours after a lost game
seven like that ears huh oh yeah some
guy goes wow you're a real fan yeah I
know don't ever tell me bad news one
time the eggs were losing in the
playoffs on a set of NYPD Blue I said
don't mess with me don't ever give me
bad news let me find out the bad news on
my own I hate that no but will you give
those instructions though Nick then you
know if they're not saying anything to
you that the news is bad right you know
what I'm saying like that's what like if
you're not hearing something that's a
problem good thing though that on your
said while you were on NYPD Blue yeah
yeah there's a heck of a road it was a
great running it started started in 96
and I was there that week against
Atlanta let me tell you the week I had I
was there game one that got blown out
like 12:00 1:00 Andruw Jones hit two
home runs rookie from Curacao yeah Kara
sounds like he's like eight years old
unbelievably Almonte was younger than
him that's right they say that 20
they're like 28 32 look at that face El
Duque Oh Duque we don't know if he was
like 40 Oh Duque I love that Duque but
anyway that week was great game today
loss to Maddux then I'm in the hotel to
Regency and a game he's won Game three
Game four was the game where they came
back the six nothing
it's insane in the uh during the Regency
all the producers were like we thought
we heard you we thought we heard you you
you heard me you heard me don't worry
and then the game 5
does the Petitte Game one not that I
think against Smoltz Wow
I had to go to a cop dinner that night I
was in the limo I'm like oh my god I got
to go to a cop dinner tonight so I
stayed for Game six I had all the juice
for the tickets all the guys on the show
Jimmy Smits David Milch and their guest
Nick asked Nick I was like yeah right
don't worry I'll get you a ticket cuz I
was making long so that was the guy at
that time but I was like I don't want to
be in the luxury box I want to be with
the real fans sure I don't want to be
with those rich mummies I gotta be with
the real guys and the real that's where
I want to be you know I mean but it was
and then I got on the field they brought
me in the locker room that was surreal
for a kid like me I mean no I gotta tell
you I mean and you know Mikey del 2 fo
ver they were in the Yankee had on he
texted me last night about what's going
on with Chapman as Chapman put the first
two on base and I said to him I'm like
this is what the rest of the world has
to deal with that we didn't have to deal
with with Mariano Rivera for 15 years
it's just unbelievable with the
exception of one time against the
Indians in 97 in a in a divisional
series and then 2001 essentially 2001
and also 2004 he didn't get out of that
ninth-inning you know where we basically
got a swept the freaking the kiss of
death was that stupid walk time a law of
all people in the law I remember stuff
about the Yankees that I don't even know
in my own life my own life is like a
blank 57 years I did so much stuff I
can't remember squat if you asked me
where I was during a Yankee moment I'm
there it's like my brother when he
memorizes all these speeches I thought
John John huh he's a genius this John
loved the Yankees as much as you or
would you like stuff he doesn't love he
loves the Knicks
he loves the next whether you he's like
I moved for both teams Nick I'm like no
no John you got to take it side no I
don't know I don't ok I can't mess with
him he's mine he runs for the Yankees
and Mets you said that's what he claims
you know he claims that he like Don
clendenon he like Tom Seaver listen
I grew up in Queens almost Long Island
that's from that's where well my brother
says the Lower East Side cuz he didn't
like Rosedale but it's all bs we've we
grew up and well he was born in Hollis
him and my brother Ralph were born in
Hollis Queens yeah they were they were
tough they went to top schools I was
soft I was a Catholic school boy you
know one block from Valley Stream he
walks down the street hook Creek you're
in Long Island but I used to rep
what would your teachers at that school
think of your videos today's what I'd
love it but I was emotional as a kid I
used to run out of the class in the
first grade I had a problem staying so
true story I don't ever want to reveal
what happened like it's all right I did
it on Coney and my mother was alive then
she was upset my dad tied in my my chair
in front of the class whatever we could
just stick to baseball yeah we don't
need to go back and rehash that but
anyway the Mets
you know I should have been a Mets fan
by landscape because I was surrounded by
all kinds of met fans and I didn't know
baseball and somehow I went to the
Yankee Stadium with the Boy Scouts 1973
and then the love affair happened I
don't know it was just magic Nick Notaro
here on the Rich Eisen show again at
Nick datura one on Twitter and Instagram
and yes your videos are absolutely
priceless you said when you were sitting
on the green room couch before you came
out here that you got a text from your
wife saying to look happy right they
don't look so angry yeah so what are you
what did your wife think of these videos
she thinks some of them she likes some
of them sometimes good things I go too
far sometimes it's disturbed our
marriage you know she said you don't
make it fun anymore you took all the fun
out of it I said I do you mean I took
all the fun that is part of the fun you
got to understand you gotta you gotta be
in pain sometimes to get the fun you
know nothing comes easy in life even
being a fan a real fan you know so she
doesn't really understand the insanity
behind it it's just a game
but but those who may not know if
they're just gonna start tuning into
your Twitter feed right now it's not
just playoff baseball like literally
like May 15th Jay Happ gives up two runs
in the third inning you're you're out of
your mind
yeah is that the is that the Yankee that
drives you the most nuts Oh Jay Happ
yeah you know I mean not I wouldn't say
him I don't have real you know I
wouldn't say was just Jay Happ it
depends
it is okay dependents in the moment it's
in the moment that's how I'm feeling
it's the vibe you know you never know
sometimes who's the Yankee that sets you
off the most history in the history of
the Yankees in the history that's you
off the most
the woman you're like oh god this guy
what do you got for me nicked it sir
oh god ed witson that was a joke how
about Jesse Barfield huh oh god he
wasn't a good Yankee how many times did
he swing at something 15 feet outside
the zone these were a lot of guys in the
eighties there's a lot of guys in the
80s that you know you had high hopes for
like Steve Kemp I thought he was gonna
be a good Yankee turned out to be a bomb
that you did you know who's a tiger some
guys cannot cut it it's like I mean you
know I don't want to say who can't cut
it on this team but there's a guy there
that don't belong I better not say I'll
make this current Yankees I don't want
to say you don't I don't want to jinx
I'm rooting for him does it doesn't
rhyme with me me and Marlo frettin
[Laughter]
myford on the next next round I'm left I
just won him on the team I want that
lefty back okay they need to resign didi
Gregorius a lot well that's that goes
without saying yeah that goes without
saying what do you think happens in the
NL series Nick what do you think goes to
the World Series out of the National
League I think they got the Dodgers got
Bueller Game five and hopefully they
don't choke I think the Dodgers will
pull it out mm but it's not gonna be
easy
Cardinals Braves I don't know the Braves
the Braves have just something about him
you know what I mean they just they're
they're young and any of these kids
could just crush it
I also think Freddy Freeman's injured
he's probably hurt he's been not good
this year yeah I mean there's a lot of
guys that I heard well you know I mean
like Dedes been hurt he's starting to
finally find it so you know it's gonna
fight find a way to get it done but I
mean a brave little scary team and it
kind of stupid to the way they play the
game sometimes you know yeah they're not
smart these guys like a Kuna there's
like somebody's gotta sit that kid down
and talk to him but they're young enough
to not know
I love Donaldson man you know I love the
bringer of rain yeah he's a beast but
he's got to come true and left too many
guys on bass yesterday you can't do that
in the postseason postseason baseball is
completely different
forget about launch angle forget about
the home run get the runs in move the
guy over because you know you just got a
chip away in the postseason you're not
gonna always put up seven runs like they
did the other day certainly if you got a
beat Verlander as the Rays have to do
our researcher right over there el Zorro
he's over away in the deep over there he
and Dick by town of the only Tampa Bay
Rays fans I know until now Yankee fans
Go Go Go you raise absolutely like let's
push them to the brink let's push them
to the brink let's let them sweat it out
let them have a game five that'll be
good for us let them sweat and anything
could happen in that game fun only thing
could happen you don't want it to come
to that you know yeah I wouldn't mind
alright so in the last couple minutes we
have left here Nick yeah who was crazier
crazy okay who was crazier you in a tie
Yankee playoff game in a game seven or
David Caruso on the set of NYPD Blue and
seasoned men that's pretty close I loved
Caruso but he was a nut he wasn't nut
but I did love the guy you love the guy
yeah I did love him because we had like
a chemistry he liked me I liked him and
you know he was kind of self-inflicted
so I used to always don't be like what's
wrong why he's so upset you know you're
like they made you the biggest star in
TV and he was like you know you know I
used to say he's misunderstood and
people would say that's your a guy
that's your buddy
I used to stick up for the guy mm-hmm
but um well worked out for him it worked
out the guy's lucky the guy got back on
TV taking his glasses on and off he was
asking me to help him I tried to help
him and then I'll say hey Dave they're
having a spinoff oh yeah I heard
something of yeah yeah I mean while I
was in a room one time yelling at all
these agents and he was sitting there
going who would have thought to Touro
would be the bad guy I was like yeah go
figure that
so but he was terrific on that show he
was really wonderful and we had some
great scenes some great moments I
remember early on the show I had very
little to do so I was like a nervous
wreck I'm like I hope I don't suck these
guys are great
hope I can just hang with these guys you
know I'm botch going Milch these guys
were like gods and I was like hey Davey
am i okay and he said are you okay
you're beautiful kid beautiful girls
whatever you got doing
don't let anybody mess with you I was
like what does that mean just it means
what it means just don't let them get in
your head okay so he took me under his
wing you know he was always like we got
to get back to the to the to the big
screen I go what get back to what David
this is great we're like you know we're
the champions of the world right now
greatest show on network television at
the time well your first credit was do
the right thing so was do the right
thing just doing voiceovers screaming
racial obscenities that was like my
first credit that's what got me a pot
spike brought me in it like scream and
in he like went nuts and he was like
Nick meant it you know and then it's
like he's the first guy that actually
told me that I think he got something I
always knew I had something but I just
had to have somebody like spike to tell
you that now have you seen him at a
Yankee game Spike's a big Yankee fan yes
I wouldn't say he's bigger than me but
he's big I don't know honestly I've
known Yankee fans
I've known him for 40 years 50 years I'm
a 50 year old guy you are I've never met
anyone quite like you you are into it
you are diehard and sometimes I do need
to see you doing what you're doing to
get me through what I'm trying to live
in and die in this sort of thing
but and I feel I've sometimes I feel for
it cuz you do really take it very slow
yet hard it makes my night a lot better
when they win I'm a lot happier feel
that sexy
since toss their own level rises let me
tell you it's it's it's known for no you
know I mean it it's a good high for me
you know even if I have to go act my
brain starts to get more channeled
consult your doctor to see it for good
if Gregorius is right for you breaking
bread I've got a great podcast you guys
got to check it out we watch it on
YouTube
it's really funny my son is like the
co-host we've had a lot of great guests
it's very good breaking bread it's you
know it's bad we have like a cult
audience we're not we haven't blown up
yet but this is gonna help so yeah so uh
so is the same son who films you yeah
film me and I got two episodes of SVU
right now so I'm going to New York
perfect timing like the baseball gods
wanted me there okay so I'll be there at
the stadium this next round
okay so that's a good sign unless the
Rays pull it out and the Yankees get
home field hey listen I mean it works
god bless we still got to win one way or
another we got to win the whole damn
thing this year we can't come up with
this lame thing you know it's ten years
but look at it 2009 they swept the twins
2019 swept them and they get by eight
these that Scrolls or whoever they're
gonna get it done
bless you Nick tutorial thank you thanks
for coming on anytime let's do it again
sir just do it again when you K any time
that we'll do it again
and we'll see how how far the Nick the
Yankees take things okay I had a blast
at Nick totora one time I'm telling you
I'm telling everyone out there you you
deserve to follow Nick deter not Nick
doesn't deserve you following him you
deserve to follow Nick to Toro and also
sometimes you got to keep the volume a
little low and make sure the kids are in
bed when you hit don't forget there's
knowledge behind what I say it's just
not somebody screaming don't let the guy
without a shirt you're right using the
poor timing is
let that fool you
that's me feeling my weight as me
feeling my sexy I'm very comfortable
with my body even though my brother said
I should lose a lot of weight I would've
had a better career cuz I just said you
were a good-looking guy you should have
been skinny NIC was but there's nothing
funny about a skinny guy my friend told
me Jackie G yes of course
NIC to zero here on the Rich Eisen show
we're back with more and setting up our
Wednesday show that's gonna be dynamite
as well in a second for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app